pendant deux décennies
j'ai fait de phoenix l'une des premières
banques européennes aujourd'hui je vous
confie le gouverneur n'allait pas
laisser phoenix sa marque tournant une
personne ne sait ce que ce n'est pas
dans le ventre
vous savez faire quoi tous tant qu'on
reste dans l'égalité est dans
l'illégalité vous proposant un salaire
annuel fixe de rémy lyon il semble
président marmandais trad millions 4
vous cherchez un président arabe
c'est exactement ce que nous cherchons
pour l'instant
fait planète une horde de fans de mulot
c'est indécent ces femmes de présidents
tu te dis comme une femme de président
j'ai profité de son poste de président
si je m'habille comme une femme d'un
président se pose trop tout ça tu peux
tout quitter mais moi je suis pas marche
arrière
nous avons fait des bénéfices et toi tu
me sens si tu dis ça commence très mal
monde
discount fort et je me place
je pense que l'argent pourrit tout
j'attendais mieux de tous pour le départ
essayez drones américains veulent que je
licencie
il peut servir à compromettre
c'est comme un chien je n'ose pas entre
nous nous allons continuer de prendre
aux pauvres pour donner aux riches
c'est un jeu enfin juste un peu cruel
certes mais un jeu planétaire et les
gens qui perdent leur emploi
l'envié quand richard dictionnaire y
jouer aussi